good morning it's 7:52 a.m. one thing
I've noticed I've been wearing the same
clothes just in different combinations
and I do have more clothes than that
but for some reason I haven't chose to
wear them so I'm up scratching my leg
not my vagina you see that the setting
has changed I creep myself out very
easily and last night there was a car
that was in a driveway across the street
and it was just sitting in the driveway
for a very prolonged period of time with
its lights on and the engine running I
just sort of looked at it through the
blinds the computer is or was situated
right next to the window it was just
sitting there forever then it's slowly
super super slowly pulled out of the
driveway and super super slowly drove
down the street so for some reason that
creeped me out and I thought that I
shouldn't sit near the windows I've
become or m on the path to becoming a
crazy cat lady but with a dog that isn't
mine the dog has been rubbing its butt
on the carpet I don't know what that
means I assumed that it meant something
akin to I have to use the restroom
I let it out this morning it used the
restroom but was also just wiping its
butt all over the grass outside too I
think it's either something severely
medical or the dog is being hilarious
I'm not the best person to judge those
things michelle is coming tonight and
also notice that I referred to her as my
secret mystery guest but also just said
her name about 30 seconds before that so
it's no secret no mystery Michelle will
be here tonight and hopefully she knows
what wiping your butt on the carpet
means she's the dog owner